let's talk about Devon Nunez if we've
learned nothing else about Raqqa
Republican congressman Devon Nunez since
he's been sort of shoved into the
limelight by his dim-witted and reckless
wanderings into interfering with the
Trump Russia investigation it is that
Devon Nunez is the epitome of the hyper
partisan loser that we should all want
out of Congress sooner than later
remember when he was running the house
investigation
he went to Donald Trump and said hey
here's what we're doing in the house
investigation remember when he made a
huge to do about his memo based on
intelligence he hadn't even seen which
he said was going to totally shock us in
terms of the partisan nature of Robert
Muller's investigation remember when he
went on Fox News's Fox and Friends last
week and he said the provable lie that
Trump and indicted adviser George
papadopolis had never met anyway
much like the presidency has been a huge
nightmare for the Trump family in many
ways I don't think the recent publicity
for Devin Nunez has been particularly
good for him and it's getting even worse
now there's a so-called news website
called the California Republican and the
California Republican was churning out
just all sorts of pond-scum drivel
promoting nonsense about the entire
release the memo non scandal and endless
other stories and the website had been
registered to a political consultant
named Alex have lien but Politico did an
investigation and lo and behold it
appears as though the news website is
actually run by the campaign of one
Devon Nunez Republican from California
and after Politico reported on this the
website for the California Republican
has mysteriously gone offline but they
put up a Facebook message saying that it
was a result of heavy traffic and an
attack on their servers that has led to
the California Republican being down
Republican Devon Nunez has been caught
running a fake news website now I'm not
saying quote fake news end quote I'm
saying a news website that is fake in
the sin
that it's run by a Republican member of
Congress in a particularly partisan one
and hey listen if Nunez doesn't like the
reporting that's out there he
conveniently can just create his own
news website and report whatever the
hell he wants here's a tweet from the
California Republican Twitter account
pronouncing that Devon Nunez is a hero
with the quote this is what a hero looks
like and it's a picture of Devon Nunez
looking either pained or constipated
unclear which is anything real about
Devon Nunez I mean bogus memos based on
Intel he hasn't seen news websites that
are actually campaign linked propaganda
this guy is one of the worst isn't he
you know what this reminds me of
remember there were a few weeks back in
the summer where the Trump
administration was putting out a show of
its own that they called real news oh
yeah and they had Erick Trump's wife
starring one of the episodes and is that
Larry from Annie
Larry Trump yeah but at least then you
knew that it was from the administration
they tried to hide this I'd love to know
who came up with this right like imagine
Devon Newton s going to some PR
consultants saying listen I'm getting
crushed by negative stories and we got
to take control back
here's an idea create your own news
website and then just publish whatever
you want including tweets that you're a
hero newness is kind of like the kid in
high school who tried to cheat on
everything but he was sort of too
incompetent to do it so it backfired and
it ended up even worse than if he just
got a mediocre grade on the test that's
the equivalent of what Devon Nunez is
doing here and the guy's got to go and
hey you know what you can vote him out
in eight months because every single one
of these guys and gals are up for
re-election in November and he's from
California - no I don't know how
conservative the district that he's from
is media but I'm sure he has a chance he
has leading yeah he has a chance of
losing and he has a chance of way I mean
it's it's you could get them out but
it's not going to be the easiest